[Musique]
car il faisait chaud par te mets à rêver
est notamment élevé jusqu'à présent
surtout ta mère évidemment je travaille
toute la journée mais si je dis partie
de mes vidéos super boulot
j'ai dit que j'étais maire anarchiste
je suis de toute façon rien à [ __ ]
d'ailleurs tu pourrais l'aider
bercy veut gagner des millions
tant que tu écoutais ni ni geysers et le
branding seul e jeux jeux à rien je vous
à nous mais que tu fumes du rail qui
n'ont jamais et puis nous a presque
terminé
jésus tu sur une pomme deux saleuses
creusera l'expérience d'un vieux routier
ça va
aujourd'hui il ne te faut un petit verre
mais demain tu en fais moi tout appétit
sans frotter de la honte qui rentrent
mois sur ta peau mr un oui mais tu es
qui pour moi est posé vous je vais vous
dire bon gène est il moins que oui eh
ben le fine art c'est pas des habitués
sache
1 alors il doit quand même y avoir une
raison elle est jolie et jeunesse
rencontré ont suivi nous sommes jeunesse
on avait la guerre mondiale d'astrid
chiot vote final 1 a souffert 1
alors après crasset et quand c'était
l'armistice tous les français en traquer
le peut fêter dix cas des américains
oui à la lgv alors nous on a dû la loire
les virant sont dit tiens ça marche
alors ils ont produit fine art à la fin
de notre saison
et puis depuis la fière de mon picole
pour aller plonger la salle on peut on
est en service nous augusto aura de
sérieux
ou pilotes tu peux pas comprendre des
patriotes et oelschig et c'est quand
même pas mon fils droit y est il va me
rapprocher de patriotes nos révoltes et
les u11 viande moi ça quand on a vu
qu'on plérin et lannion chante on s'est
dit on va faire des gosses arrière -
contre pour la synchro rien sur la
déplie cnit
ils veulent prendre un fait régner même
le jeune allemand bayer qui veulent
point fr chairman milliard en d1 vais te
dire qu'on voit la tristesse des pique
niques
on comprend pourquoi ça cardy logic et
on se dit que pinard quelle autorité
monsieur coluche vous avez des enfants
dans la vie des jeunes veulent pas
comprendre et vie je suis une fusée mois
très difficiles oui vraiment non merci
ont bu en partage alors mais toute
l'année
voilà et qu'est-ce que j'en fais je le
mets je le garde ou le devrait très bien
ou demain matin
oui vous aurez l'occasion puisque nous
retrouvons à 12h30 et dans quelques
minutes vous allez retrouver pour le
journal de tf1
il vous y comme chaque jour à 13h alors
je dis un petit bonjour arrive comme ça
en passant j'agite mon pied si je puis
dire parce que je crois qu'on est des
compagnons d'infortuné mais tout va bien
un bon rétablissement yves mourousi et
bon journal en tout cas et à vous tous
bonne journée au revoir c'est avec
beaucoup de plaisir que nous vous
retrouvons demain au revoir au revoir
vous botter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]